je ne suis pas sûr que vous seriez bien
le personnage monsieur le commissaire
pascal sellem mais rien d'autre qu'un
agent double plus connu sous le
matricule et x 76 et tout cela n'était
couverture finalement dissimulé pour
passer désinformation allez vous allez
au foot et moi ce mythomane en salle de
dégrisement a envie d'aimer ce que
promet ça vous êtes manipulés
j'ai reçu défense
la défense l on n'est pas arrivé
les grèves et les manifs je reviens j'ai
mis deux heures
c'est un rendez vous
moi je peux vous proposer un truc en dix
minutes on peut y être ah ouais
ouais
c'est parti
g
pardon petit mathieu on va y aller en
hélico un génial
voilà
non mais ça suffit
j'ai demandé un taxi maintenant c'est
vrai qu'il est qui va prendre à veliko
ça ira plus vite 1
mais je ne veux pas
je vais vous dire tout de suite
pour 22 22 francs
si si allez on y va
non
je n'ai pas le louper dit dans
ces j'étais un peu en retard bras
ces gars là ont des reflets de radars ok
bah maintenant qu'on est tranquille on
va pouvoir procéder à un échange
ronald pognon vous avez décroché
le film profite c'est quoi cette manie
de la bassée les changes c'est les 100
briques j'avais pas le paquet de clopes
avec le micro sim
[Musique]
vous êtes un cercueil
bas et donner le mot de passe aussi
quelques places j'ai pas dis je à la
défense
qui vont aller en forêt vous avez dit
d'une façon
qui m'a mis la puce à l'oreille je
pensais que c'était fou un peu si on
m'avait dit lui est ringarde
des lunettes gentil
mais le passe aussi et d'abord la
connerie
[Musique]
un vent frais avec les randonnées sans
censure je vais voter pour
[Applaudissements]
la battait
hollande
la fournée 2
je vais foot à orléans
on réserve un taxi avant l'énoncé bon
dans le taxi aujourd'hui ça va aller
bonjour d'un traité sur les doigts
comment je vais vous faire un bon c'est
pas tout [ __ ] ça serait sympa ça elle
peut déposer sur le parvis avec
l'échelle de corde
le sac il baissera à non sans câble il
ya des trucs fragiles marais oui là les
quatre oui ça bon d'accord c'est
fastoche un tel bond de l'oeuf et bien
je veux pas pourquoi vous y arriverez
pas à dechy pas le bon bout alors vous
n'êtes pas à quoi c'est pas belmondo
en tout cas j'ai fait un bon tour
l'électorat mais non mais c'est surtout
l'histoire du
cinéma
enfin s'il veut bien
je crois que ça avec à la télé
[Musique]